practice school is about learning how to
get worked on in the real world we're
really interested in establishing this
problem solving ability in a real
setting bringing the human dimension
into it you all should just be sponges
you should practice the practice school
offers students an opportunity to go out
and do industrial research projects at
different post companies they're very
very bright they're very energetic
they're very excited to be in an
industrial setting the big challenge
that we would like your help with is
adapting the etch process the projects
that Corning gives us our very real
projects there's a few issues with the
current technologies that we're hoping
to solve with the support of MIT if we
knew the answer to these things we'd
write it down wouldn't we we don't
that's what research is we're advancing
the barriers you're going to come up
with ideas your ideas could be really
great ideas but if you don't do anything
with them they're worthless you gotta
move you want to strive for impact again
the clock's ticking I feel like
everything we've been working towards
just colliding into this crazy mess
we're going to get results we have to
analyze them we have to present them to
our group and the slides are going to
talk for themselves and you're just
going to carry on a conversation with
the audience how do we do this we are
trying to develop a theoretical model to
explain what we have found a little bit
better and we have made some
calculations but then yesterday during
the night we realized that there was a
pretty important mistake what we had
done the things that seemed as if they
fit really well with what we wanted to
didn't fit anymore by several orders of
magnitude which was
pretty bad so we had to stay a little
bit late trying to figure out how to fix
it it's sometimes not only difficult to
get done what we need to get done but
difficult to figure out what we needed
to do in the first place working with
bob has helped a lot he really made us
critique and analyze how we present
ourselves it's not all about technology
and knowledge in science it's a lot
about dealing with people we recommend
studying the effect of putting multiple
glass lights next to each other it is
the drive to understand the drive to
have impact the drive to be curious
about why something works or something
doesn't it really helps people be
successful in industry we promised our
big customer to have this technology in
six months and it seems like we proved
that there is possible much faster and
then thank you for that work I really
appreciate that when we presented our
final results and they thought of
actually achieved what they asked for
other people higher up in the company
came to us and congratulate us and
wanted to chat about it so people say
it's really really hard work and it is
but bully it's fun so first we have if
they come out performing at the same
level as when they came into this
program and that's a shame something
didn't happen success for me is when
students identify a new skill to
practice a new way of being in a
professional environment that makes them
a better engineer sometimes a single
thing can make all the difference good
job today
you